hi everyone
my name is miroslav divi and i would
like python to get me home as quickly as
possible
cities are one of the greatest
inventions of the humanity
imagine thousands of people living not
far away from each other
and improving their economic politics
and culture
but getting around the city is not very
simple because
usually you have several ways on how to
get from a
to b and getting around the city doesn't
look much
like this it looks more like this so if
you use
mass transit or a car you just get
into the queue with other people
traveling on the same
mean of transport and then waiting and
moving moving moving
at the same speed but there are some
other individual means of transport
for example walking or cycling that are
really very individual
because everyone bicycles
drives at a different speed and uh
everyone has a different way of
accelerating braking
everyone behaves differently in front of
different
obstacles and for example on such a bike
strike would you go near the cars when
any time
a door may open or would you take a
different road
and here will the door open
or not so what i wanted to know is
how fast can i get from a to b i took
some random app
with a real-time online
navigator for my cell phone and then i
told him okay i want to go from the
castle in the
center of the city to some place in the
suburbs
and this app told me okay you can take
for
example you can take uh here one of the
busiest uh
roads in the city or would you like to
go
directly through the zoological garden
where you are not allowed to take a
bicycle anyway
so let's take a look at another app
and it proposed me a different uh
route and i thought myself hey which one
is the fastest one to get from a to b
so i exactly as the second app proposed
i
just do this this route and
i measured it tracked gps
and i saw that oh there are some places
where i had to stop because there were
some lights
and maybe there is another possibility
how to get
from a to b so what i did i took several
rows from a to b and different one
and also i tried to
not only to go from a to b but just from
c to d and
from home to work from some other places
and then i recorded all of them
and i tried to find some
rules uh or some
[Music]
way to identify which is the best way to
get
from a to b and then i
loaded i did plenty plenty plenty of
trips and just for this uh presentation
i just
tried just through the three of them and
i loaded them into uh joseen
and then tried to find all the
intersections
and all the points of interest so for
example we have here a crossroad
where there are some trips going from
between
different points and then not
automatically but manually i
found the points where of intersections
and then i defined a new um
network with a bath between these
spots and um then i saw that okay there
are also some
crossroads that are not only simple
crossroads where you can
turn left right to go straight ahead at
any time
there are also some crossroads with
traffic lights where you are not allowed
to turn
left where turning right is much faster
than going straight ahead
and this way i
built a whole network
there is a project in the python because
i wanted
to write a real project in
python on github which is called apigo
home
using a few third-party libraries for
geographical
and mathematical computing and
iplay flat and apple widgets are
libraries for
jupyter notebook representation
interactive
work with the data on a map
and then i took my all my
trips and then tried to find all the
intersections
and manually enter them
to the gpx files
at the end i had a network of
all the intersections and all the roots
these are not based
on the map so it doesn't use any map
information it uses only
the data from my gps tracker
and then for example here to get from a
to i
there is one root there is another
possible root
and there was a third root but you see
that for example between a and b
that i have already two data and this is
exactly what makes it individual because
if i go on right on the segment
between two intersections uh it depends
on my speed on my acceleration braking
on my behavior
or in front of obstacles uh on the
currently weather on the current traffic
uh current route condition um
that when i take some segments several
times or many times
i will get a lot of data um a lot of
time data like
this number of seconds uh passed between
points and a b and i will get some
mathematical
this distribution or mathematical
representation
of how fast can i get from a to b and
then composing it uh to a bigger network
how to get between any two points
because then
i could take a trip for example from g
to c and then
you see that probably the fastest route
maybe
a b e f i although i have never taken
exactly this route so this is manhattan
distance that i'm compiling
using much more data that i would have
only if traveling between a and b
then with this data i could build some
statistical representation
so for example if i go if i have a
segment that goes
through the city uh and there is a
traffic light so it can take somewhere
between four and eight minutes depending
on the traffic light
and there is another way around through
a park
which is in the average is a little bit
slower but
uh there are no lights so actually i
will always
need around six seven minutes uh and in
this case if
i statistically try to try to find the
best
route i can say oh i am feeling lucky so
it's sunday morning nice weather nobody
is there
so i will be actually in average will be
faster than the average
uh in this case the route through the
city will be faster
but if i want to make sure and i want to
get uh somewhere
and make sure that i won't need more
than a certain amount of time i will
try to see in the upper limits
of the distribution and in this case i
see that going
through around through the park is
actually
faster than going through the city so
this is how it looks like you can go
to buy go home download it try it with
your own data
or there is a mybinder link or
button where you can click and it will
load and then you can upload your gpx
data
and test them and then choose
some two points in your surroundings and
in the quantile you ask zero is the
fastest uh
one is the slowest the safest one and
then it will
tell you how far how much time you need
it so for example in this case
uh between the castle and the park
i needed uh nine minutes and 11 seconds
in the fastest case but the slowest
with all the lights and traffic and
everything took me 22 minutes
on the other hand if i ask for the
safest route it will give me this one
because the fastest time was actually 11
43 which is a little bit more but i was
never slower than 13 minutes and 18
seconds
there are plenty of things that i would
like to work on
if i go home um i would be happy to hear
your feedback
so there is something like isochrone map
i have a point and i want to know
in which area i can get within 5 10 or
15 minutes
it should automatically detect the gps
problems uh detect brakes and vehicle
swept so for example if i just
get off the bicycle and push for a while
they take that edit intersections
automatically because now i do it
everything manually maybe some machine
learning depending on
which is which weekday or day time is it
integrate with openstreetmap with the
data from the map
avoid and prefer tracks and maybe do it
everything in postgresql without using
python at
all and maybe up app or some more
platforms
i would like to hear from you thank you
very much